so Donald Trump has reportedly fired or
had pushed out dr. Rick Wright who was
leading the effort to develop a corona
virus vaccine allegedly because Rick
bright was refusing to promote
chloroquine Trump's preferred
coronavirus treatment at least up until
a week ago it was truly stunning and
disgusting there are two sides to the
story I'll tell you both of them dr.
Rick bright was the head of Barda the
biomedical Advanced Research and
Development Authority since 2016 on
Tuesday he was abruptly reassigned to a
narrower position he says he was removed
and transferred because he resisted
promoting chloroquine which Trump had
been promoting for weeks until multiple
studies showed it's not only an
effective in treating corona virus it
may be dangerous to people if they have
corona virus bright admits that he was
against pushing for promoting
chloroquine saying quote specifically
and contrary to misguided directives I
limited the broad use of chloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine promoted by the
administration as a panacea which
clearly lacks scientific merit while I
am prepared to look at all options and
to think outside the box for effective
treatments I rightly resisted efforts to
provide an unproven drug on demand to
the American public I insisted that
these drugs be provided only to
hospitalized patients with confirmed
kovat 19 while under the supervision of
a physician these drugs have potentially
serious risks associated with them
including increased mortality observed
in some recent studies in patients with
kovat 19 that's right Trump was talking
about what do you have to lose maybe
take it prophylactically that
unfortunately is not though what you are
supposed to say when you are under the
thumb of the great leader Donald Trump
who says chloroquine for everyone maybe
with a z-pack maybe with zinc or both
now Trump of course played dumb during
yesterday's press briefing and I have
thoughts on this here's how Donald Trump
responded when asked about dr. Rick
bright Rick Bryan he's the head of the
federal agency in charge of getting a
vaccine out to
once it's ready he says he has been
pushed out of his job because he raised
questions about hydroxychloroquine and
some of your directives on that was he
you just mentioned the name I never
heard of him in the desert this happened
today
guy says he was pushed out of a job
maybe he was maybe he wasn't you'd have
to hear the other side I don't know who
he is so my instinct is it's possible
Trump doesn't know the guys name but
he's familiar with the situation it's
possible that this came up as one of 10
things someone brought to trump and
Trump said remove him and he genuinely
doesn't remember it's possible that this
was the action of someone in the Trump
administration and not of Donald Trump
himself who made the decision to get rid
of Rick bright I mean there's a few
different options here it's also
possible Trump is just lying he lies all
the time and it wouldn't be surprising
to see Donald Trump just straight-up lie
about this even though he knows exactly
who dr. Rick bright is I don't know now
to be thorough there's another narrative
here which is a counter-narrative the
narrative is that the Trump
administration did reassign Rick right
but it wasn't because of the chloroquine
thing that they've actually there's a
report that they've been trying to get
rid of him in this position for a year
and they finally succeeded this week the
timing is certainly suspect will we ever
know the truth probably not but dr. Rick
bright is filing a complaint with the
Inspector General of course we know how
inspector generals have been neutered
under the Trump administration as well
next I do want to talk about how Donald
Trump was once again triggered by CBS
news reporter Regina Ruiz out the first
500 people who see this video and go to
david pakman.com slash skill will get a
premium membership to Skillshare for two
months completely free skill shares the
online learning community with thousands
of classes on almost anything you can
imagine always taught by experts they
have classes on drawing painting
photography video editing web design
running a small business and much more I
recently took a very interesting class
called simple
productivity how to accomplish more with
less and got a bunch of great personal
productivity tips out of it we should
allow ourselves a little time every week
to either get creative keep your brain
sharp learn something new it's great for
mental health and almost all the classes
are under an hour so it's very easy for
someone who's busy to take advantage of
it with Skillshare you can discover a
new passion explore something you didn't
know you would enjoy but there's also
plenty of classes for people with
experience so you can just get better at
something you're already good at and
again the first 500 people who see this
video and go to david pakman.com slash
skill will get a completely free premium
membership for two whole months giving
you access to every class Skillshare
offers check it out I put the link right
underneath this video